this doesn't go down and easy this is my
there's enough explosives in here to
send us into orbit
you want my help I'm gonna need two
things from you the first is I'm gonna
need you to say the words I am the green
arrow truth is I am Iron Man hey
everybody it's Charlie so we got a whole
bunch of arrow flash in four-way
crossover for next year stuff to talk
about Stephen Amell was teasing next
year's crossover he went in to talk
about season seven with the arrow riders
room in the past couple of days but they
also pitched him what next year's
four-way crossover is going to be so
obviously we have to break that down
with all the arrow stuff that's gonna be
happening next week because if you
didn't know the arrow finale is next
week even though the flash is a week
behind so I'll explain the schedule at
the end of the video too but be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video so here's that clip of Stephen
Amell talking about next year's four-way
cross over what would it be I don't know
but I also don't know how you guys are
gonna do another crossover because oh my
gosh
oh I do I do yeah I know I got pitched
that too yesterday I think there's gonna
be some news coming up about that it
when I got pitched it the good thing for
me about the show is it's impossible to
say how long you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna do it I don't totally foresee a
Jared and Jensen any situations yeah
tied I don't those guys started younger
than I did
and there's Kenzie's and there's two of
them right so technically going into
season seven there's just one of me so I
think I'm gonna count it the same way oh
yes when I got pitched the crossover
yesterday I was as excited to hear that
pitch as I was when I got pitched that
we were gonna be introducing Barry Allen
you know all those years ago so I'm
still it's still just as excited and
enthused about doing the show the cool
thing about that it doesn't confirm that
they're introducing a new character he's
definitely making it sound like they
introduce a new character because he's
as excited when they first introduced
Barry Allen during season two and that
was probably one of the biggest moments
in the history of any of the DC TV shows
because at that point we did
have the flash it was just arrow so it
was like oh by the way we're introducing
one of the biggest characters in the
history of comic books on our show and
he's gonna get his own show right after
this assuming this isn't gonna be some
crazy setup for Titans on the DC
streaming service or anything like that
the newest characters like really big
ones that are really exciting that
they've just introduced but haven't done
a deep dive on yet or Barry's children
as a big idea that the flash is dealt
with this season so they could be using
that for some crossover stuff because
it's gonna be the Flash's hundredth
episode so just something to think about
while all these finales are happening in
the next couple of weeks the flash
finale isn't for a couple more weeks
arrows is next week but Stephen Amell
did say that they might be announcing
something soon so that means we might
get a formal announcement of what next
year's four-way crossover is going to be
or some sort of teaser that'll give us
an idea for what's going on but talking
about arrow finale so last night's
episode Oliver had a version of his Iron
Man moment with the FBI agent so now the
idea is is the FBI can balance the
scales a little bit but after they beat
Diaz inevitably he either has to go to
jail because he's come clean now and
he's guilty of all the things that the
FBI agent said that he was guilty of or
she lets him off the hook so Stephen
Amell did say that there would be no big
cliffhanger at the end of the season you
would know exactly where the characters
will pick up in episode 1 of season 7
next year so obviously there'll be like
some big moment they go out on but it's
not going to be are they alive or are
they dead kind of cliffhanger like that
was after season 5 Diaz effectively
destroyed the arrow bunker that could be
them saying that there won't be an arrow
bunker at the beginning of season 7 or
they could be moving it to a different
location they still have the other
bunker that the new recruits have been
using but they might just be setting up
the idea that there is no arrow bunker
officially at the beginning of season 7
because Oliver's off doing something
else or he's in prison if the FBI makes
him do a couple episodes in prison Diaz
in the quadrant though the whole idea
when they set them up is that they were
supposed to be this crazy organization
in Diaz has already killed almost three
of them it looks like as of the end of
this episode so it's like Diaz taking
control of the quadrant but you do
wonder like he kills those bigger
characters do they not have anyone
underneath them that's going to seize
they
power for their part of the quadrant we
could talk all day about logic problems
but I think the whole idea is is that
the quadrant is supposed to survive this
but Diaz is attempting a coup right now
we'll see what they do with them is an
organization during season seven but
it's kind of ridiculous the Diaz is
steam rolling through all them like if
you're someone who's a member of the
quadrant then arguably you have to be
crazy powerful crazy smart so it's weird
the DS can dispatch them so quickly
either that's what's going on like
they're just having some logic problems
or they decided that they don't want to
do quadrant in season seven so they're
like okay we'll just have Diaz kill them
all even if it doesn't totally make
sense but as for the finale trailer
footage really all you see is what they
left you with at the end of last week's
episode so you have Oliver talking to
FBI agents like he's come clean so he
has their support now so they're getting
ready to roll out
you see Diaz getting ready to blow up
what looks like a very important
building like they wouldn't be blowing
something up if it wasn't super
important so I'm guessing this is either
City Hall or it's some big government
building and a bunch of people will lose
their lives it just looks like he's
trying to twist the knife in the wound
that is the city like he has been slowly
destroying it he's co-opted pretty much
everything even the quadrant isn't happy
with what he's been doing which is what
led to him dispatching those characters
but you see Laurel with Quentin I know
we all have the theory that Quentin is
gonna be the sacrifice because they
announced that Paul Blackthorne is
leaving the show after this season so
it's like gonna probably kill him off
and use it for some Redemption art for
laurels character they tease that she
might be the one to take down Diaz
because Oliver hasn't been killing
people as much like when they came to
his house Williams like are they dead
and all it was like no they're just down
for the count so he's trying not to be
like the old Oliver anymore but black
siren has made no such promises so if
they're any bodies that get dropped it's
much more likely that black siren does
it but you do get the traditional finale
big rooftop fight between the main hero
in the main villain so they'll at least
be some huge battle between the two of
them maybe Oliver spare says life then
black siren is the one to finish him off
I think the real question now is is
who's going to be the season 7 villain
will we get a teaser for that in the
finale the flash does that every year
they give you an idea for what's
happening in the future season but they
don't always do that on arrow like
during the arrow finale it was just a
question of who's alive and who's dead
at the beginning of the season they
didn't tell you the Diaz was gonna be
the villain even though we found out
about that I'm also wondering what
they're gonna do if they go past seven
seasons because Stephen Amell said that
he's already crossed off all the things
on his bucket list they've done all the
things that they want to do so that's
usually something you say before shows
getting ready to wind down so I don't
know how many more seasons it'll go it
just depends on ratings but what'll
happen is is next week we'll get the
finale so we can start talking about
season seven after we see that will
still have an episode of the flash left
hopefully we'll get that teaser for the
four-way crossover or at least the
concept pitch like oh this is kind of
what we're gonna be doing without giving
away the entire plot but remember it
wasn't a little bit later in the year
that we found out about crisis on Earth
X so they might wait till Comic Con to
announce what they're actually doing for
the big crossover but that's happening
at the end of July there's also a rumor
that titans is going to drop during the
summer and when I say summer I'm talking
about the end of the summer so after a
comic-con sometime so like tail into
July sometime in August that late in the
summer so I am expecting a bunch of
Titans Young Justice season 3 DC
Universe streaming service stuff to
happen at Comic Con too so we'll start
talking about that as we move through
all the finales but leave all your video
requests in the comments below
what'll happen is is they dropped a
Death of Superman trailer so I'll do a
video for that later but I have some new
infinity war to post and obviously
there'll be a whole bunch of DC stuff
happening in the next couple of weeks
but while you wait for everything click
here for brand new flash and click here
to learn about the crazy 70 episode
order that Rick and Morty just got Rick
and Morty season 4 thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight